lula da silva was received as a hero in
sao bernardo do campo in the state of
Sao Paulo
if there is one place where the former
labor union leader is loved it is here I
want to build this country with the same
happiness that we built it when we
governed this country my dream isn't to
solve my problems today I'm a guy that
doesn't have a job a president without a
pension not even a television in my
apartment my life is totally blocked the
only thing I'm certain of is that I have
more courage to fight than before
on Thursday the Supreme Court said
convicted criminals should exhaust all
their options to defend their case
before going to prison
this benefited Lula and many others but
Lula has not been absolved and still
faces at least seven other cases against
him many here believe that she's the man
to challenge which also narrows
presidency
Tomas Calvo says Lula is the only one
that can save Brazil is most afraid of
because he is our representative he's
our leader and this country will change
for real with that beautiful man outside
but in the capital so Paulo thousands
marched through Avenida Paulista to
protest against Lola's release they
condemned the Supreme Court's decision
and are calling for a change in the law
that would imprison those who lose their
case in a first opinion there is so much
impunity in Brazil and we want things to
change
we are denouncing the decision so Lula
can go back to prison jail wall senado
asked his followers on Twitter
not to give ammunition to a man he
called the scoundrel he also defended
his Minister of Justice Sergio Moro who
as a judge led the car wash corruption
investigation his impartiality in Lula's
case has been questioned and that's why
Lula is requesting a retrial brazil is
polarized between those who love lula
and want him back in the presidency and
those who are angry with the corruption
that happened while he was in office
Lula is planning his political comeback
he's already a war zone eros biggest
political rival
Theresa Bo al-jazeera são Bernardo do
Campo Brazil